on va revoir une image qui a beaucoup
circulé sur les réseaux sociaux le
député françois ruffin vêtu d'un maillot
de foot à la tribune de l'assemblée vous
le voyez c'était ce jeudi lors de
l'examen d'un texte visant à taxer les
gros transferts de sportifs
professionnels
l'élu de la france en soumises s'est vu
infliger une sanction financière pour
extravagances vestimentaires
il voulait porter un message politique
sur ce sur ce texte sur ce texte
ou est-ce que ça vous choque une
sanction est ce que c'est adapté c'est
ce que la direction a justifié la
sanction est justifiée cette ligne choc
il ne faut pas oublier que nos
concitoyens travaille tous les jours
payent des impôts pour que nous soyons
dans cette assemblée nationale et que
nous travaillons tous les jours pour eux
et je pense que certaines manifestations
manque de respect envers cette
institution et par conséquent envers les
français
on est là dans la politique spectacle
qui ne respectent absolument pas le
règlement qui demande une tenue correcte
et digne le port de la cravate
ok c'était pas nécessaire alors vous
n'avez rien plus ce règlement juste à la
mairie nissan a de toujours d'une bonne
partie exact l'histoire de la cravate
l'histoire du drapeau de l'histoire de
nos deux vols du brio de foule et la
question c'est finalement que veulent
t'ils apporté à la sombre exactement la
france insolence que veulent t'ils
apporter à ses tables en est cette
assemblée nationale quel message veulent
qu'il a apporté et je ne comprends pas
un vrai manque de visibilité aujourd'hui
quant à leur objectif poli mais alors
justement là il y avait un message que
voulait porter françois ruffin il avait
mis ce maillot justement pour alerter
sur ces gros transfert qui on pourrait
taxer pour financer le
le foot amateur m'a finalement il
dénonce une approche un peu lucratif du
sport donc ce message vous le n'at-il
pas des mots pour dénoncer cela n'est ce
pas le lieu notamment où les mots sont
là et ont un poids on vient passer un
message
oui nous sommes nous sommes nous sonnes
législateur avant tout nous avons aussi
l'interdiction c'est dans le règlement
de brandir des objets à plusieurs
reprises leur france insoumise a brandi
des objets dans l'hémicycle il faudrait
la lancée voilà lorsque l'on fait la loi
il faut pouvoir en premier lieu la
respecter aujourd'hui la france
insoumise a tendance à ne pas respecter
le propre règlement de l'assemblée
nationale et je pense que lorsqu'on
parle de probité pour les français et
pour la vie politique il faut commencer
par soi même et donc il a une sanction
ils sont tout à fait essentiel sera
diminué d'un quart pour ce mois ci